es una carrera loca para ponerse a salvo
mientras los misiles rusos caen sobre
esta ciudad ucraniana un equipo de
pilotos de drones del ejército ucraniano
se pone a salvo en una casa abandonada
Bienvenidos
están operando en la línea del frente a
las afueras de la ciudad meridional de
pergomaisk una parte del pueblo está en
manos rusas los pilotos instalaron un
satélite para mantenerse en contacto con
sus comandantes
hay un lugar para escondernos es un
edificio bastante grande es difícil
encontrarnos aquí nos da acceso a todos
los lados del edificio
estos hombres y su equipo serán clave en
la tan esperada contraofensiva ucraniana
son los ojos que los comandantes de kiev
necesitarán para dirigir el ataque para
mantenerse fuera de la vista del enemigo
los soldados instalan sus antenas en el
interior vuelan sus drones desde un
punto entre muros de hormigón y lejos de
ventanas
Antes de que los drones entraran en
juego el reconocimiento se hacía a pie
básicamente es un pequeño grupo de locos
reuniéndose despegando al amanecer
tratando de maniobrar entre las
posiciones enemigas y tratando de
obtener la mayor cantidad de información
posible
sus aviones teledirigidos recorren la
campiña circundante para detectar a los
soldados rusos y su equipo en cuanto a
lo que descubren estos hombres están
obligados al secreto absoluto sus
hallazgos se dan claves para el éxito de
una contraofensiva que no termina de
llegar